[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from nine nations converge in
st. Louis as US chess champs dot-com
presents the second annual summer chess
classic hello and welcome back to the
2019 summer chess classic today is going
to be round six I of course and one of
your hosts joined with Jessie cry my
name is Caleb Denby and today we're
going into the second half of the
tournament so the players had a rest day
yesterday I don't know how much resting
actually got done but hopefully they're
coming coming back rejuvenated renewed
and ready to play some some interesting
chess why don't we take a look at the
standings we have right now for group a
it looks like Jeffrey Zhang and David
Howell are still tied for the lead
coming up to to catch them is actually
Sam Shanklin who got off to a slow start
actually lost his first round game but
with a win in the final round moves back
up to even just a half point behind the
leaders Gawain Jones has been playing
solidly all tournament and is also on a
level score Lee Ann Lee is at two points
along with Darius Swedes hoping to maybe
catch out and over in Group B Surya
Ganguly jumped out to an early lead in
Group B starting off with two wins and
then since then it's been all draws for
him in that remaining time Grigory
oprand has actually caught up to Surya
so they are tied for the lead at three
and a half points trailing them are
Havana's kuboos Ian in Sam seven both
with a level score and rounding out the
group is Daniel Freedman with two points
in Igor Kovalenko with one and lastly in
Group C archers Mike Suns has the lead
in this group with three and a half
points also a plus two score but in the
last round Alshon maratti Abadi and
Aramco Cobian both managed to win their
game jumping just a half point behind
the lead now Dimitri Gordievsky is on a
level score with two and a half and
rounding out the group former group
leader Brandon Jacobson and Christian
shrila account so especially in this
group seed there's a lot going on
who do you think has the best chance of
catching up or does archers still have a
firm grip well a lot of it depends on
today's game where else Shawn has
planned our tours and he I think else
Shawn has a nice position so it's gonna
be the first time we're gonna see
archers have to defend and we gotta just
gotta say when that section is that our
genius Brandon Jacobs have wandered to
the queenside in his last round wasn't a
pretty sight I thought he was totally
winning we thought he was totally
winning and then we left and then he
decided to wander over the Queen side
and then it was suddenly all over so
yeah yeah definitely an interesting
situation in all of the groups that gave
right there you can see him he's
wandering about his position now I think
he's better so we're just gonna say even
though he's down he's last lost two
games I I still think the kid could
catch up we're gonna talk about that
game when we get into it well let's
introduce the tournament format what
kind of format these players are playing
under there are three six player double
round robins so this being the second
half all the players have seen each
other once and now they are facing each
other again
this time with the colors reversed the
time control for every game is 90
minutes for the first 40 moves with 30th
minutes sudden-death for the remainder
of the game there's a 30-second
increment from move one as well as well
as a 30 move draw rule in effect so no
drawers before move 30 and we can take a
look at our schedule the round starts
every day at 1:00 p.m. the only rest day
for the event happened yesterday so it's
just chess from here on out and then on
that final day the games will start two
hours early to account for the possible
playoffs you can join us here on the
broadcast at 3:30 p.m. two and a half
hours after the start of each round
coming up actually though on Wednesday
is the Grantchester in Croatia so if
that tournament happens to run a bit
long we will be coming on directly
following that grand chest to our
broadcast and they'll definitely be
exciting stuff as well always you can
join us here on YouTube we're reading
the chat if you have any questions for
us any questions for the players we're
happy to take a look at that and try to
try our best to answer your questions
you can also join us on us chess champs
calm if you're interested in following
the games your
live and finally you can join us on
Twitter using the hashtag summer chess
classic and with that in mind let's just
jump into the pairings for group a Liam
Lee is paired against Darius roots David
Howell one of the group ACO leaders has
already drawn his game against the
number one seed Sam shank lint and then
our key matchup for the day is going to
be this game
Jeffrey Zhang also leading the
tournament is paired against Gawain
Jones who has not been defeated yet this
events they receive aboard and gowing
Jones thinking hard about his next move
it's been quite the game Jesse quite an
interesting opening and now we're in an
interesting maybe end game yeah it's
this has been one of my favorite games
so far and a lot of great games this
tournament but why don't we start from
the beginning and we have ourselves a
group felt and so far this is what
Gawain Jones has played already a couple
times we've had this against Howell as
well and one nice thing I like about
Runa fell players this their opponents
always prep really deep for them but if
they have a lot of these green felt
players like going I feel have a very
good intuition of how to deal with
problems as they arise in the board in
fact both English players generally tank
in the opening pretty deep and so this
happened and after 92 I could tell that
Gawain was kind of out of whatever was
normal for him but here was his response
the very typical Greenfeld response he
plays snip and queen d8 and now f5 and
here you know I I could tell Jeffrey
didn't know quite what was going on this
is very typical stuff though where he's
going to be threatening f4 and that's
gonna undermine this point he's also
gonna maybe under my efore so I love
seeing this
sometimes when I'm unfamiliar in an
opening I take more of a safe cautious
approach but it looks like Owen kind of
sensed the urgency the position and just
immediately is breaking open the center
well right if he doesn't do anything
it's gonna be worse so I thought okay so
just my my my week GM sensibility was
like let's take the pawn and see what
happens
but Jeffery thought for a long time and
played this really spicy move 95
thereafter which there is all kinds of
complications
you could have we could have played f4
he could have done other things
he played going played Bishop e6 and now
this move which is again a spicy move
Queen a four so let's it's trying to
talk about it when we can out come to c4
and this will now be with a check and we
yeah we want to be able to recapture
with a check basically when that happens
black again could have done various
moves here but he goes for it with f4
okay here we go
Bishop c4 is going to come and now going
decided the Bishop c4 was no good for
whatever reasons and instead goes for
this madness Bishop e5 Bishop e6 King g7
and I assume what he figured was going
to happen was if Bishop d2 I'll snip
here and if this gets snipped then I'm
gonna snip here and open the rook and at
least castling will be difficult total
mess but check out this move the
Geoffrey play and again I will say in my
experience so far
Geoffrey is the best calculator just
being able to find moves like we're
about to find here Queen B 5 okay
Intermezzo is piling on each other here
and there's a couple problems obviously
there's this but the threat of Queen b7
is also very unpleasant because the
knight doesn't really have any great
spots to go to so here we go
fe 3
rook f6 and I think this was let's call
it a the well the big moment here
because white had two choices what he
did in the game rook c8 which is very
hard to see what's gonna happen after
rook c8 and another move that would have
been very spicy is g4 Wow
for example and the idea is like okay if
you take I can do this because I can
hang out on the light squares because I
own the light squares and you know
there's this problem in so one variation
you know there's all kinds of things
that could happen here
so what if he I guess if you tried to
choose the simple approach and just
Castle there would be something like
knight c6 maybe attacking the Queen yeah
we don't have time yeah no time to get
no time and right now we're gonna say if
knight c6 I'm going to snip it Wow I'll
do this alright you know so anyways that
was the other option okay so rook c8
takes and I like this a lot this was
really beautiful a nice clean sacrifice
and it's very difficult if not
impossible basically it's a how
impossible to hold on to the bishop on
e6 now you could have also played King
f1 and there the interesting thing was
that knight c6 snip-snip it's still
really hard to deal yeah when this comes
rook t4 we're gonna have an extra threat
say king you too might have been the
right square then they were both
interesting I thought they were both
interesting after this it's hard to
imagine that white is gonna be better
let's put it that way
because King f2 snip and now yeah we're
let's let's update this board here we
had rook e1 and rook f6 check black no
actually
rook f6 check
we're gonna I have a feeling Black has
his own notions about what's gonna go on
but when I said no danger I was thinking
of a position like this check and then
as long as I play rugby for I have a
fortress
there's no way in interesting was white
forced to play rookie to in that line
you mean Ricky maybe not but it's just
you know it's a real question who's
attacking who here like if I get that
rook on d2 if you let me stay there
well my idea is king g1 no huh and then
whatever movie play maybe rook v2 right
or Rick s6 now okay rook f6 it'd be very
tempted to just take b7 but maybe rook
f2 is too strong let's look at what he
did yeah so he's obviously saying that
maybe he's trying to transpose to that
line and if King g1 then Rick d2 well
it's an interesting question if you're
black like I think you're you know
you're so close to the fortress that
Millay it's almost like he's trying to
get it'll get to be a little spicy here
with on his own here where so King g1
and then Rick d2 is extra so played King
G 1 repeat soo good and now I'm assuming
rook F 1 is kind of sort of forced
so in that fortress-like position say
Yorick f1 happens and a pair of rooks is
traded and then something like hurt B -
I was always under the impression that
if white can kind of watch those Kings
side pawns there could be some serious
threats against the black king still
something like h4 h5 and going for h6
I'm a little upset that we didn't win
this pawn I'll say that's why I wanted
to check on right over there
let's I'll tell you what let's put but
first let's say that if white wants to
bail he can do this and then this is
just gonna be a draw of course so I save
over here and rook f1 seems like the
only shot I don't think if a paradox
gets traded it's gonna be hard to win
for white but I don't see any way white
whatever lose this I don't know if
that's fair to say yeah no that's
probably fair I don't I don't see him
winning it either though well there is
this plan right if I just play h4 and
with the idea I'm gonna play g4 and h5
how do you stop my my pawns from
advancing
well we're probably gonna assume brick
f1 is forced no Geoffrey's already
surprised he and a number of times this
game after this I was mulling over which
way black should go should he take here
or should he play with me too
let's say rook a to first second rook f1
has been played by the way let's say
queen b7 and now I assume we're gonna do
something like this near its YouTube so
I'll just I'll start with H for now I
just have to make sure my rook doesn't
drop off the board and I guess I want to
it I want to come in - sure I think you
might also I might also want to play a
five so I don't even maybe you might
even want to start with Queen a six yeah
I was thinking about playing I don't
know it just seems without the F pawn
the black came King seems a little Airy
to me for this to be like a fortress
type draw but I mean I'm I'm no expert
in this type of a type of endgame by a
long shot
well for the chest as I hear one basic
fortress you can imagine is you know if
you sacrificed your knight for the pawns
and put you and lost these two put the
rook on f6 king f7 then it's totally a
draw mm-hm
so the weird thing is is like White's
the one that's the consolidate his
position here da black because black is
gonna come and be active himself he just
has to make sure that his rook doesn't
drop off the board by some nasty check
it would be nice you know right if I
could maybe put the Brooke on a more
secure Square okay so I don't know if I
trust this plan and put in the community
five because the Queen can make some
threats
you know from b3 can jump into f7 or or
g8 I think what is true is that after
rook f1 I did again I'm not I was still
a little uncertain about rook f6 check
but
is first of all I guess we're not we
don't really not even technically in a
rush I don't think to take so you could
play you're okay to work me to here I
think the only difference really is that
I can recapture with the king and claim
that that's a little bit better but
honestly it's so similar that I'm not
sure it makes a difference he's
obviously thinking too about some other
thing hey think about other things
idiot he had some notion when he played
rook f6 all right well let's come back
Caleb thinks there's a chance that it
could be broken Brooke f1 was just
played and I well if anybody can break
it it's Geoffrey yeah he's he's one for
the long haul you know he he's not
afraid to sit down there for the next
four hour is it and really get it done
Magnus Magnus does n't believe in
fortresses and maybe Geoffrey doesn't
either gonna be going on for a while
why don't we take a look and see what's
going on in Group B yes sir pairings for
this round our Daniel Friedman paired
against Sam sabaeans good news ian is
playing against tournament co-leader in
the B group Rory Oberon and Igor couple
unko as pair against the other leader
Surya Ganguly in our key matchup of the
day sory of course jumped out to that
early lead we see him there on the
screen and since then he's kind of a
stagnated a little bit with three draws
in a row in the past three rounds so
maybe today he's hoping to switch it up
after the rest day he's ready to get
something done although he does have the
black pieces against an intimidating
Evora Kovalenko well right and igor took
the fight to him and played i think of
let's call it a sideline so we got this
Botvinnik variation it doesn't turn it
doesn't go full about Vinick here
when white chooses a four and I was
watching this game over there and you
know it's one of these moves that maybe
I've seen at some point and I think
maybe Ganguly felt the same way he had
to think here a little bit and I think
the let's if you want to think of it
from a let's call it a theoretical
perspective the disadvantage of a
is you get to shove the knight back and
now ask the e4 pawn a question of course
the advantage is white is gonna get to
play Bishop c4 at a very very suit
you're gonna lose your happy pawn that
normally wouldn't black plays this is
the the pawn is not only a healthy pawn
on c4 but it also blocks this bishops
development so that's the advantage
so let's look white says alright I'll
give you this Bishop and maybe Caleb
will remember but ganguly had another
game with an unopposed bishop I was
around 1 or 2 we won a very nice game so
this was mildly reminiscent of that a
very impressive game that one as well
so Kovalenko played this next move
pretty quickly and I was like whoa I was
like well so let's say normal moves here
would be things like castles and E 5
Kovalenko played a5 and clearly this is
the kind of thing at least I think you
wouldn't do unless you'd kind of a
little familiar with it Black has so
many different things he can try to
throw at you and it's got just
controversial because you're not
developing your guys so the point is of
course to stop black from playing a 5
because that would solidify that pone on
b4 well I'm not convinced you know black
would play that right away I don't think
that's the ID main idea not at the
minute
the main idea is that when the guy goes
Bishop d7 I want to spank at home and
there are many variations I want to keep
the knight out of b6 so also maybe on a
tickle this pawn ok right so it's very
controversial though because white is
now you know he's handing the
development over to black there's only
so many Tempe you can give up even with
the white pieces you know you play
Knight c3 Knight back to b1 now a 4 and
a 5 so black definitely is going to be
ahead and maybe development here and I
think one of the I think one of the ways
white could say or explain this does if
he was here would be to say well I'm not
rate I can do a 5 anytime I want
and I'm not necessarily ready to Castle
because I am dreaming about maybe
playing he 5 92 94 and then h4 with my
own attack
so maybe the rook wants to be on h1 is
what he's saying and that maybe I can
hang out with the King so very
enterprising play Queen c7 black had
many different moves here
ee 592 d5 i thought for a second he was
going to gambit the pawn who with 94 and
then or just simply rip c1 both of those
also seemed interesting
Rippey 8 III and this is very
interesting play black you know black
had several different ways of going
about it and here he's gonna sack a pawn
to gain the be 4 square and if the pawn
is captured them there's also pressure
with the rook right on the b2 pond
especially and I like this this net next
move might not be technically the right
move but I like it the spirit of it I
feel it's the spirit of what White's
been going for the whole game he goes
Queen b1 so you know making a claim
about the fact that we have who we have
this big fat pawn in front of your King
and we need to create grief where had
interested in winning your Queen side
stuff so on the previous turn how do you
evaluate a move like east 6 ears for
white that would be something I would be
considering is trying to open it up I've
got my rook on the e-file my opponent
really doesn't yet and is that something
worth considering here maybe I don't
really like it too much though because
you're gonna activate the rook and
you're giving me a free developing move
work and okay this is kind of the best
piece like black probably wants to play
Mike play Bishop e6 soon anyway which I
think he does in the game so Queen b1
damn that's maybe why you wanted to do
it because he's late yeah now if I
capture that piece my my pawn is I got
strong on e5 but it's also keeping my
rook out
right and this was a this was a big
committal decision to play Bishop e6
which definitely has its drawbacks
because now the games gonna change
really with the pawn structure so we
take and now White's gonna say look
because this rook is now defending and
and creating its own drama I am NOT
going to be able to launch things like
94 Knight g5 instead though I can start
talking to this guy so queen d3 and
we're looking at maybe moves like Queen
c4 black then goes for it with 95 and
this is our current position it honestly
I think I'd rather be white here it
looks like there's gonna be long-term
pressure against Knight a5 mmm
I don't know about it because yet I
assume something like let's just put
Knight c4 on the board there might be
something better but let's just put that
on the board and it's gonna be theirs I
like the rook
I like this pawn it's one of those
positions where black has the extra
material but it's kind of stopping up
his own pieces right his rook stopped up
at the pawn on beam theory is Queen is
stopped by the the pawn on c5 and let's
look at what egor played he played rook
a4 interesting
so still eyeing that King I think right
well it's weird because rook h4 is kind
of if you're gonna attack the King you'd
want to play rook h4 so I want to be
honest I don't and you are stopping
black from playing c4 that's important
of course you could have done that with
Knight c4 as well so I wanted to jump in
here really quick and ask you a little
bit about the tournament psychology
going into this game ganguly of course
is leading the the B group he's tied for
the lead and we see you work or
Kovalenko there who was actually having
a bit of a tough tournament he's on one
point out if I think five and so he's of
course probably Ganguly sees this as an
opportunity right if anybody is having a
bad tournament it's gonna be Igor and so
he thinks this is his chance to win so
as Igor how do you come into this game
knowing that this guy's gonna kind of be
coming after you
and as ganguly how do you come into this
do you approach it like you're playing
for a win or do you just stay solid with
the black pieces oh I think Ganguly is
playing for murder here ya know he
doesn't care and he's played Ganguly
before these guys have seen each other
they know what's up and Brooke k4 I
didn't get it at first but pretty great
move it was at least the idea is pretty
simple anyways we're we're gonna tap the
night with either the rook or the Queen
and then we're simply gonna win this
pawn and claim that our LightSquared
domination is going to be forever and
black really would like to play c4 to
you know get this Bishop going so in
contrast to my move Knight c4 which
allows black to get rid of his Knight
rook a4 is saying no you know what I'm
gonna make your Knights suffer head it's
a bit misplaced so I think there's gonna
be resources here for Ganguly but we
have a total mess in transyl
well definitely can't come back I want
to answer a comment in YouTube will this
be broadcasted when the grand chefs tour
starts on Wednesday is actually when it
starts and absolutely absolutely yes we
still will be broadcasting if the
Grantchester event happens to run a bit
long we will just be coming on directly
after that broadcast ends we'll still be
here you'll still get your your daily
dose of the summer chest classic and
actually let's move on to the C group
now we haven't taken a look at yet so
the C group pairings have Christian
Trillo playing against Brandon Jacobson
who Cobian is playing in some Gordievsky
and tournament leader archers next ons
actually has the black pieces against al
Shawn Marathi Abadi who is chasing him
trying to catch up so al Shawn's big
chance to take the lead
might come in this game and this is of
course our key matchup of the day and
let's see what's going on over the board
we say our Terra's hunched over there
thinking about his move and Alshon
coolly walking away yeah I think Shawn's
got a very nice position
one thing dedicated fans will remember
is that our tours played a very nice
Marathi bind against the count and the
count was obviously uncomfortable
playing the bind and now Naik's ons has
been playing the bind in got a very
let's call it a bad version of the bind
and promote eyes on the black side and
else China has been pressing most of the
game you can see here that the night on
e 8 is terrible this game is far from
over though let's let's back it up a
little bit and see what happened
one thing I've seen with our tours and
I've known a lot of other Latvian guys
and they love to play kind of funky they
like the funky so it starts off as if
we're just traditional people here we're
normal people but then it starts getting
a little weird and then night a6 this
movie night a6 is what really struck me
is a little odd yeah I'm I'm gonna say
our tours definitely didn't like the way
it went
so after a rookie won the let's say the
normal move would be to play 94 but
there's several weird things about
playing 94 here one of which is in this
position that let's say standard theory
or whatever you want to call it is 94
here and Bishop d2 now notice when the
way black played Bishop b4 checked
Bishop d2 he wants to claim that the
bishop on d2 is misplaced
so of course it would be kind of weird
to suddenly play 94 now in this position
so our tours definitely playing on the
wild side and now it's stuck into I
think a clearly terrible terrible
terrible Roxy bind and not only that it
gets worse here with b4 and then the
night is absolutely miserable so this
story of this game going all the way you
know where I move 14 in this position
all the way to the game position with 29
is else on trying to dominate the Black
Knights so here we go f4
v e5 was a committal decision but the
idea is simply to dominate the night all
right
there it is and we're aiming for this
beautiful c6 square do you get that as
well
you know and it looks like I mean it
looks like either it looks like a clear
advantage it's called a clear advantage
there's that terrible night and here's a
nice move by leshan b5 which is so
unpleasant now if this Knight comes here
there's two moves that are hard to meet
both Bishop g5 and Bishop before forcing
rook e8 then 96 probably Bishop g5
actually because because then if you go
like it just takes away more squares if
we're a cafe then Bishop e7 you know so
the natural move not possible our tours
has to play the sad-looking 98 but one
thing about these positions is even if
your pieces are terrible the these
Hedgehog positions have a lot of
resilience so even if you have one bad
piece it's not necessarily the end of
the game and white on the other hand
well you know have to eventually think
about his pawn on e5 and that's why that
move e5 that L shouldn't play to move 17
was so committal or as Sam Shankly would
like to say pawns don't move backward a
497 c5 and at the very least black can
be happy with the fact that he's traded
off some stuff and let's look at what
happens here so Knight takes Knight c7
Bishop d6 95 or c6 I think you know very
nice play by L Shaun it's not over by
any means but let's just say as we
follow this that the hope is not only
for the outside passed pawn but that
we're gonna get a Fischer endgame with
rook
against rook and Knight and yeah black
King looking a little unsettled there on
g8 maybe something like h6 will have to
be played and then but but the good news
it's is here it'd be hard to actually do
anything with white plus the knight on
d5 is a made of stone and the bishop on
d6 is a proud piece right but it's kind
of unhappy really with this pawn on e5
blocking his way to the other side of
the board
so some technical challenges for sure
for us Shawn but yeah it's difficult to
find ways to kind of Prada at blacks
some cases here cuz like a7 is possibly
a weakness but after okay six I don't
know how you pile on anymore pressure
really yeah like I said I think we're
gonna you can aim for like King f3 rook
C 1 and then trade a ripoff is what CA
okay let's go back up let's go back up
to the top that's the key matchups out
of the way and so what else is going on
what's interesting well first we got to
check in on Gawain to see how he dealt
with the situation so we were wondering
about rook a to and B - he chose Ric B -
and the advantage of rook B - is that
the knight then at least becomes
invulnerable so the disadvantage though
I think is no white can consider things
like a4 and that that pawn might be able
to run up to a5 when black would have to
stop it with I guess a 6
well black immediately says I'm not
worried about those bonds high-five
himself now we're gonna get this h5
thing so as far as I can tell this is
like a common idea right the White Queen
alone can't make threats against the
black king and the White King can't
really make its way that far up the
board so why uses the pawns as that
extra kind of a extra piece to make some
threats yeah well me and Caleb have a
little disagreement my intuition is that
it's not that big of a deal for why
there's definitely practical chances I
think there's real real questions
Gawain's asking about a4 a3 or just G H
actually on GH
see any real hope for white to create
drama but he plays a four Gawain's a
fighter the guy doesn't care doesn't
care
now here's an interesting thing where
you know I like I said it's not clear to
me who's got the advantage I guess I
would say it's equal but what if I play
a queen up for here
okay what's your you want to play you
want to do the thing to me I want to
play h6 no I just need one or two dark
squares and I'm there I'm in so yeah I
don't know Thanks
so this is yeah this is a little
unfortunate
I wanted to play something like if you
were to take on the previous turn I
wanted to play Queen g3 and then have
some squares on the on the Queen side
somewhere so I'll play Queen g3 first
why just ask why not Queen g5 or you
want to do a trick to me if I go to h8
or something yes so you'll come to f7
and then I want to play Queen f3 and
keep you I guess from coming back to g7
or then I go to g6 and then Queen f5 and
King g7 we're back where we started
right yeah okay so Queen g5
let's say King f7 take your pawn with
check not too proud right and so uh I
guess King g7 and then but Gawain you
never know with going he like King e6 we
six literally now the only event you
know he's gonna dream about it but right
King g7 and then yeah I'll maybe give a
check and put my queen on d5 with the
check if you let me and then I will play
something like G for now let me just say
maybe G for but I was gonna if you want
to do this to me don't might be don't
you want to do this yeah I like that
idea as well because when you play G for
there's no you're just attacking with
the Queen and you don't got anybody else
yeah I like your idea a bit better on a
second
on second thought but you don't you
don't believe it for white no okay no I
think there's practice always practical
chances this kind of thing so h5 a4 and
yeah so we'll keep an eye on this it's
funny I often times you know you you you
form an opinion of what you think is
going on and then you talk to these guys
and they'll shrug it off and be like oh
it was a drawing the whole time where
they'll say you know oh I was lost the
whole time here so it's interesting to
ask him and we might get a chance to do
that let's look at da Rose game against
led VM and I thought that the Liam had a
nice position very early on but now I
have to say I'm not sure at all what's
happening
let's take a look it was this this thing
I've experimented with in the English as
well so you play Queen c2 it's like
you're playing a Sicilian with reverse
colors right black sniped and there's
you could take with the Queen but he
takes this one and then does this setup
and I thought to myself this is great I
said to myself this is beautiful what
you've done here because we've got the
bishop and we've got an extra center
pawn and so it goes like this
a ch3 the intention what is the
intention I get to put the bishop on III
without being molested by 94 and so this
I think is like God let's call this a
night off players dream and the
difference between this is a night
orphan with if you compare it with a
night off and what we've got here is
that there's no pawn on c7 there's no
pawn on b2 which you would think would
be to whites favored because he's got
the bishops and kind of wants it open
but here's the thing it's still a
challenge of what to do going forward I
didn't I thought this Bishop was kind of
funny hitting a rock and so now let's
say this position or somewhere out here
is when White has to come up with a plan
and he ends up with a plan of pushing
the F pawn and and maybe that's not the
way to go
so my most natural plan in any position
like this would be to try to trade off
my a pawn for B 6 but maybe that's not
achievable here no that's his strong
side of the board we don't want to mess
with it okay okay that was on that troll
and now here's where white goes for it
with 92 like all of a sudden what's
gonna happen if you play a 4 and you
don't get control of that let's call him
the black hate squares on e5 and d4 that
the Knights are gonna end up becoming
strong so let's look at how this happens
92 bishop basics making at least night
c4 a little difficult now 93 notice the
only thing that the thing does on 93 the
thing the night does on ib3 is it
controls a potential square in 94 but
otherwise it's dominated by the b6 ball
so already a sign that things are a
little funky night if a good move where
are we going we're aiming for the dark
squares f4 committal ni g6 very nice and
already I'm starting to like black a
little bit better it's it's a mess but
when I compare it to what I thought why
it was better out of the opening and
like I said now I don't know
a difficult position it's tough too
tough to play move with white I guess
black is is bike actually threatening to
capture directly on d3 or is the pin a
little bit a little bit scary well you
know let's just say even if we can't
take on d3 and white definitely has to
worry about it even if we can't we can
make a number of building moves like
even the very simple f6 is a nice
building move for black f6 King h8 white
needs to do something here's my big
question yes is d4 but d4 that will at
the very least I've got night c4 Knight
c4 I I I have to take it but I don't
want to take it I guess there's just
gonna be a threat of my rook and I
thread it on my e pawn as well right he
is thinking about d4 though because what
else you know it's kind of a bummer if
you like when you imagine like not only
the 93 threat but like what are we doing
if you move your knight mb3 then 94 and
you're worse so uh well let's look how
bad is this d4 because it looks like
maybe he has to go down that road this
pawn is weak so once you make them boys
you commit then the pawns are either
proud or they're weak and Knight
Seaforth can you play something like
Queen c1 and give up the dark square
bishop instead of the light squared
bishop I would be very surprised for one
I think I can just do that oh and maybe
I can't actually get maybe a f7 saying
at the end but of course this is just an
I think that's just a nice position
Queen takes even with the the two Center
pawns evening
this might be as good as it's gonna get
so they're calculating this kind of
business right now and honestly when you
look at it you don't play d4 you're just
of course the other option after divorce
before it is to capture the knight and
then I'm not sure what's going on well
it was like if white goes down that road
you almost have to give up the rook whoa
but you're losing this pawn here yes so
that I'm saying you might have to give
up the rook here uh-huh
but that can't be quiet right you can't
play something like rekha for I think
because something like Knight e5 might
be dangerous there's a lot there's a lot
of nature in this position yeah yeah so
definitely I don't like taking on c4 it
but maybe there's something here so
let's just say that in this position
let's say this one here which looks so
nice for white now let's call this a
knight or structure and say this pump
you to flee dominating a lot of these
pieces and the whole idea of the
Sicilian right is you got an extra
center pawn and that that pawn does
things ever make so we got that and then
we contrast that to our current position
and that's our that's the struggle that
we got facing us now there we are
oh let's go some other games this is a
gonna turn into time pressure for sure
all right white did move he decided I
cannot do d4 and instead played Bishop
f4 and I guess that's that's an
acknowledgement that we're worse because
at the least I'm assuming Knight d4 is
pleasant for black he might have
something else but 94 is like well I
know I've got the blockade yeah it hurts
it hurts it's not surprising that he
found something wrong with v4 there's
everything's hanging ya know it's it's
very very loose loosely tied together
okay so where do we want to go let's
look at Samuel sevens game against
Friedman and
you know Friedman has been playing a
very solid tournament and this game is
not an exception to that I felt like he
got his best opening so far where Sam
chose to play a Kings Indian old and I
thought I tell my mind this is the kind
of position that Friedman is very good
at we get White has a small space
advantage this kind of position and a
lot of times black plays see six-year or
take is you know when you look at
Bronstein's book from the zurich 1953
term you got like loads of games that go
down this line and so it's like the
old-school variation where white is
holding a very small space advantage and
has to corral the black miners and
freedmen it's very tough to do so but I
thought this position was nice in city a
lot of different moves he can do in a
position like this he could play b4 you
play rugby one he chose Queen c2
everything comes off and black says I'm
okay and then it turns into a big mess
this night a - I was like well if you
had to do that then already things
probably didn't go your way
why not the more natural 90 - lets see -
one reason is kind of a funny squirt as
well and the night on a2 is talking to
this guy so I assume that comes and then
night before it's gonna come and they
got to worry about 93 yeah this whole
thing and it's it's let's just say it's
roughly equal but some could claim here
that his King is a little bit better and
at some point he can throw in Bishop d4
so yeah they're still going on here
there any claim to d6 being a bigger
weakness than the White King no those
the other thing actually the desert 53
book showed is that the d6 pawn it's
very tough to actually do
I'd stick up you can imagine there's
always just like Bishop FA right and we
don't want to do bishop if you give me
the new Bishop f8 then I will admit that
you have an advantage okay okay so let's
look at our friend Ganguly and what is
transpired it when truck a4 it's quite a
few changes we're gonna work coming
these Goods good time for sure with c4
snip snip so at least I can really found
a file there on the C file because this
piece is major pieces at least I think
we're relaxing that this is a cool move
he continues on the path of saying I'm
not gonna trade the night I will make it
move first
fifty-eight looks good for white this
should be a don't I don't trust me was
like Bishop d8 you know it's seems like
I'd like my queen and my rep to both be
able to move to that square whenever I
need them to and now with the bishop
there is everything feels more awkward
it's a pretty instructive game where you
see this a lot in these positions where
black keeps the pawn and unless the pawn
actually does something and I don't mean
like look just trying to become a queen
later but does something in terms of
hemming are pieces in by our I mean the
white pieces if those pawns don't do it
they're just kind of blocks to be hit
and that's what it looks like here black
just played a move here
let's see what happened so queen c6
happened and then we snipped on a7 thank
you very much so now Ganguly needs an
idea after this I assume it's to
penetrate to c2 or something but we're
about to find out immediately I mean
well he's got Bishop b6 probably first
right okay and then I guess the Queen
has to go to be 77 interesting I don't
know if we want to invite the Queen over
there but that well I'm just trying to
imagine what the intention here was
maybe he's gonna play Bishop d6 and if
Queen e7 Bishop c5 and then Queen b6 and
just pile up on that f2 although I guess
it's not so hard for for white to defend
it in that line especially Oh Queen c5
it might be more natural in any case
either one of these you're inviting my
queen to start talking to the h7 plonk
yeah I guess Queen c5 white could just
take it and then the knight that's true
that's true
I was just thinking on the other
yet that with queenie seven and then
also this night thing so you know I kind
of want to go back anyway and yeah so
Queen b6 like that's just 94 is is
bringing more pieces to the Kings side
defending a defending age or f2 and a
lot a lot looks wrong for her black here
you know one thing is funny about this
tournament is you know you can ask
yourself well what's the difference
between these monsters who are like hi
2600 or 2700 and the Magnus Carlsen of
the world and the fabi's and I think one
difference that I'm noticing is they get
into more time pressure we've got loads
of players here that are addicted to
time pressure the two English guys oh
man they're in time pressure every
single time and this game you know as
well both players we got loads of moves
left
loads of moves and you know mistakes
will be made
there's just inevitable mistakes will be
made when you got to this situation it's
funny to that Queen c6 was played pretty
quickly and you know what else what did
you expect the guy to do he's gonna play
Queen a7 maybe a little simpler is night
c4 trying to fix blacks major problem
here being the night let's take a look
so Knight c4 there are still tactics
everywhere though just tricks e1 and
then I'm a little lost
yeah there's a lot a lot of problems
look c1 creepy things even if I just
take the pawn I don't know quite what's
going on
I thought b2 might be hanging you know
but the the problem for black is i if I
start attacking you know I got the gist
lot of water juice stand this for a
second this is gang Cooley's big moment
yeah he's yeah and he needs to do stuff
that's your big decision time big
decision time and you know this
tournament even though Kovalenko is only
got one point you know you win this game
you're gonna start feeling your oath a
little bit firmer yeah it just gets
thrown wide open
Oh Gangu you run it at a time buddy the
sole thing I feel like he had he must
have had some idea because okay h3 he
played queen c6 and yeah I just took his
guy sorry Gary saw it I think you know
you didn't just hang that guy and h6
played that can't be it I just can't be
it alright let's see what's good on you
so on the board but not yet on the relay
he got h6 and I got a lot of questions
after age six
we've got rook a five is a question
let's just ask that question first well
what's wrong with her okay five I guess
blacks trying to say I get the b2 upon
in the ends and that's worth the two
nights and maybe even what he was
thinking to himself when he initially
played queen c6 I was wondering is he
thinking to do this right and then you
can imagine some kind of nonsense like
this where obviously black is hoping
that there's gonna be enough counter
play before you get made it a pretty
similar situation right so this way you
get an escape square and it's basically
doesn't cost any time because you'll
check on c1 and the King doesn't really
want to go there anyway I think it does
cost you some time though because if we
go in the same line wreck a five yeah
and Bishop a5 Queen a5 and then I take
the pawns now I think there's Queen
takes b4 here right and you don't have
Queen c1 check to step out of the way
that could be unpleasant yeah
well something else has happened yeah he
decides it's funny one cool thing
actually about the move played land
let's go back here so after age six
Kovalenko said I'm gonna keep it simple
with Queen d4 and one nice intuition
there whether it was technically the
right move or not it's just that he's
saying I don't want to take your stupid
Knight your knight is terrible it's not
worthy of my rook and instead I'm gonna
keep my rook on yeah this thing's by
this Knight just has to move someday
this is actually very consistent with
how he's been playing right every move
has just been saying no your knight
doesn't matter your knight doesn't
matter and so why would he change now
why would he take that night off the
board and notice if he goes so he goes
in now Queen c2 I'm assuming well just
to tie down the white pieces cause
otherwise what are you gonna do I don't
know I I mean I agree here I just it
looks very very difficult very very
difficult Queen d4 a great practical
move the other one you can imagine that
was just complicated you look at that
position I don't know what's going on
right with Queen d4 we say we've got the
better King your Knights better knights
and you know this these this pawn on b3
is only scary if if you get down there I
was a nice move Queen before I liked
that a lot especially in time pressure
you know you gotta ask black okay you
still have the same problem supposing
the same questions what are you going to
do about it
oh man Ganguly buddy come on buddy
once again I'm always impressed by the
the composure shown by the players at
the board and the time pressure here I
guess you are shifting around a little
bit but they just look stone-cold this
is another day another day at the office
for them they're just looking at the
board taking it move by move with
seconds on the clock yeah move their
night so we can see your clock
okay so we'd see two that's kind of what
I expect he's not really threatened
anything but it
least he's making it a little more
difficult to play Queen before yeah I
guess knight c6 as well it is one idea
to look out for right I'm white here do
you think about Queen d6 sure actually
you know after giving Queen d4 such
praise we do need a follow up here and
and it is a true you know one things
funny is that maybe he didn't understand
ok 91 is play oh yeah I that I did just
just sprung into my head and that one
nice variation is on knight c6 we can
take and we're holding our queen yes
okay so 91 and let's move the Queen's
that it's obvious spot lean f5
so 96 is still a threat I might play
rook c1 here Queen f5 was played I like
rook see one it still highlights that
night yeah
now maybe a rook see it looks nice we
have to we do have to worry about
fishing p5 though I'm not so worried
that's so worried about Bishop e5 I'll
play Rick c7 and then and then further
yell out that your night a night 500k
silly
so takes and like takes okay I
understand the yelling out so okay like
yelling out of the night we thought he
plays an IDF three first yeah and let's
ask the obvious question what's going on
with knight c6 and i'm gonna assume some
simple move like queen c5 so I guess
night of three is also aimed it at night
c6 not being as strong defending the e
pawn and freeing up the Queen to move
off of the defense of f2 you know it is
true the night is going to come back to
life and maybe a variation could be
something like knight c6 Queen C 597 and
just ditch these pawns and say well at
least now I'm kind of sort of playing
yeah Knights aren't that happy in
addition to Bishop d6 we can dream about
night f-4s and stuff as well that is two
pawns though that's that's a lot to
commit to you so we actually see Queen
f4 on the board right so let's look so
90 f3 and Queen over 4
I'm not sure I'm thrilled with queena
for feels like flailing kind of but like
let's ask the obvious question with
Queen c5 mm-hmm now a five might be a
bad square but I'm willing to bet the b7
is a worst square so I don't think 97 is
is anywhere on the cards in addition to
that I guess we have there's more than
one move another move would be Knight d3
right yeah that's very nice allowing the
Queen trade but pointing out that the e6
is going to have some issues something
like that right so okay Queen f4 it
looks definitely unpleasant Kovalenko
you know these guys are so good at just
playing playing nice and smooth and they
got their 30 seconds yeah once again the
composure is really something to behold
Koko's definitely played some good
practical moves so I'll be interested
there's a 93 in Queen c5 93 is the move
just to try to make your life really
simple or at least pretend that your
life is simple and well they heard
composed you do see a couple body
language tics you might say you know
Egor temporarily twirling that rope in
his finger shifting with the rook again
a little leg jumping around maybe but
but overall I think very good nerves
everybody in this tournament is fair to
say the man who is like my opponent can
hit any number of different ways and I'm
just waiting to see which one yeah 37
seconds I apologize for not going to the
other games but let's just stay for a
second longer this is very tense I'm
interested a lot of what the decision
means or easy 6 hour hitting e6 hitting
v4 can you actually defend both pawns
well the pawn on b4 is an attack because
of this guy but it will be after Knight
d3 right so we see Queen C for Queen C
form
how do you advance in your white knights
actually that night on d3 is starting to
look a little a little out of place
maybe 92 here
well 92 Queen d5
he plays rook d1 now is there now
I assume finally it's time to bring the
knight back to c6 maybe some dreadful
thing happens to me when I do plane I
see six a Ganguly buddy bring your night
baby he could about Knight b7 I guess as
well would be another attempt to bring
the knight back in mmm-hmm yeah one of
those who is I I'm not sure about Queen
b6 I don't know it looks like an actual
square but maybe it allows blacks and
freedom okay so Rick d1 and we're wait
all right let's skip to another game
yeah a lot going on in the C group that
we haven't looked at anything and we
haven't looked at the thing I wanted to
talk about this one game with Brandon
this was quite the quite the opening
quite the quite the everything honestly
oh my god that's something I was
unfamiliar with let's just show the
opening this thing g3 night a3 e 6 g 3
g5 there were some traditionalists
upstairs at the chess club here who were
taken aback by this thing I think it
makes a certain amount of sense when I
was a kid I would have definitely said
this is horrendous but Gary the Jeep on
has had a remarkable career especially
in the last 20 years a variety of
openings where the simple idea is not so
much just to it like attack the king
brutally though it sometimes develops
into that but to displace the proud
knight on f3 and so that's what we get
here I looked this up in the database
and this precise move order has been
played several times so at the very
least Brandon got as he's gotten almost
every game
he's gotten a lead on the clock in the
early going but one thing I will say
that's interesting is when you anybody
out there you get a position as crazy as
this my move hey you've probably already
in a little time pressure even if you
haven't even let's say you're black and
you haven't used a lot of time it will
turn into time pressure so this is the
madness we began with and let's jump to
the game where we have complete madness
and oh man I don't know what have the
Queen's are getting traded on and it
looks like the count
I think the pawn missing some pawns
counts however there is a significant
problem after King b2 namely where does
your poor Bishop on a4 go got to go all
the way all the way back I think well no
first he's gonna oh this is a nice
sarasu move I'm gonna play Knight f2 and
claim your Bishop well okay let's toast
looks toast king c3 and Knight F 2 is
already played okay I'm resisting the
urge to say should have counted the pots
you did resist the urge well I came
close so I think this is two pawns down
and you know let's just say one great
thing about so Brandon I think we I said
earlier on people should just let him
win so he'll play chess and not go to
school right but I think he's gonna go
to school after this tournament because
he needed some encouragement but he
clearly a genius player really blew it
against Al Shean that was a critical
game then blew it against art tours the
two now leaders of the tournament he can
still come back he wins this turn wins
this game he can still jump back into
the standings so everything's still
possible there I actually got a chance
to play Brandon we had a local blitz
tournament here Saturday night after all
the rounds and in round
oh and Brandon decided to play a couple
players actually played I believe
Gordievsky was in it and unfortunately I
had the terrible misfortune of getting
paired against the guy
and we don't have to talk about what
happened in that game but uh let me tell
you Brandon I think is feeling a little
bit better now feeling a little bit
better after after the events of
Saturday night
so speaking of Gordievsky he looks like
he's on top here he played the Sicilian
I despise called the con Sicilian and he
played it in a way I despise to where
you know he does this little dance for
the Knights
and I think despicable stuff despicable
stuff my sense is the easy way for
whites have done this was just to take
on c6 and launch your business with f4
or queen g4 immediately but okay the
problem maybe three is that it gets
arguably just simply misplaced on v3 so
we get this business and black this is
what the calm players like to do they
like to do this little squirmy thing and
the night on b3 is misplaced and of
course like all Sicilians he's got an
extra Center pawn so this whole business
happens and all of a sudden I looked at
this position I said well maybe
gordievsky's just better so I'll take
the Bonnie says I don't mind whatever
you're doing because I have g6 and
simple chess by Gordievsky he's up some
stuff he's got the better King and
that's gonna lead us to this position we
have here which I'm assuming is just
winning he's up the exchange and white
has some proud Knights but I don't think
the b6 pawn is long for this world
black played rook c8 there's no rush
will later be able to play moves like
Queen b7 I mean yeah especially the
white King I think is a big factor here
right not not a lot of shelter for that
guy and the lack of a rook okay
now eNOS let's check in on our last we
left him we liked his prospects but said
it was gonna be difficult let's take a
look at how this went down
so Brooke see I did call that Brandon
will remember f6 okay
rook b8 rook d7 a fine I like this a lot
the way he played it so snip snip check
to them as well King King h3 I have some
reservations about king h3 and let's
just say that black is gonna try to get
counter play yeah thanks you gotta play
I've played a lot of blitz games I've
played a lot of board games I get
checkmated a lot on the h3 square like
this especially with rook and Knight
combinations the rook ends up on h2 the
night checks the King away everything
looks looks scary but the good news for
black is that if rook d2 we have Bishop
f4 black however said no I'm coming
right away g5 these guys are in know now
they've made it they've made it now with
or at least more I'll be out okay
nothing
so they both made time pressure mhm get
some pawns off the board and well black
I think he needs to mate or die right
this is a made or die situation yeah we
can come back to this game but I did
want to say breaking news for Kovalenko
has actually come out on top in the time
screen okay defeating Surya Ganguly who
was leading the tournament going into
this one so let's take a look and see
how that happened maybe we can get Igor
down in the studio
yeah well that's look so we we were a
little hesitant about Queen d6 right
Queen c4 happened rook d1 knight c6
Queen d2 he's looked like time pressure
moves me rook c1 and now back and that
was I guess what the guy missed Oh too
many too many loose pieces it's tough to
hold it all together
so Queen d2 the idea must just be Rick
c1 Rick c1 and if he could take it back
I
he would want to do something like 97
mm-hmm and he might be worse because the
pawns might simply fall but the night
will eventually get some good squares
who have come back from the edge of the
board yeah you Benchley might get some
time with some kind of play over here
with Bishop d6
definitely the type of game you love to
see from somebody who's not having the
greatest tournament right they really
will come and come to the play they come
to stick it to the leader and play
spoiler get themselves back in the
standings yeah yeah so hopefully we'll
get an interview with Egor coming up
soon and let's take a look at our other
games
Samuel does he have a shot I predicted
he might have a little bit of juice a
little earlier and yeah it looks like
he's made some progress Oh
so Bishop d7 Queen d2
that's not a good sign when you got to
play rook e1 so wait oh right so if
Queen b7 we have rook a - I'm gonna
guess that was already a mistake with
Queen b6 that's right you buzzed you
needed to have an idea when you did that
Randy and rookie ones not a thing you
want Bishop d4 is a thing black ones oh
yeah
threatening Queens takes g3 he didn't
even he didn't even deign to take he
didn't even deign to take it well you
can't you can't
this is this bad news on the h3 pawn no
this is I guess lost yeah not so
pleasant not so pleasant so strong
seankervin
Sam here Sam actually I don't think he
has one managed to win a game yet I
don't think he's lost a game either and
he's the number one seed in the B group
so despite his young age she's
definitely looking to make a serious bid
for for winning this group and maybe it
all starts here for him and the only
thing intelligent I have to say how this
position over here is that the bummer
when you play for a space advantage like
white hat and some pieces ended up
getting trade off it's almost like the
space ends up working to your
disadvantage because it's no longer
dominating any black pieces so all of a
sudden like there's space for invasion
Li Queen D dude so yeah that looks good
for Sam going to this in Freedman it's
yeah that guy is solid so to beat him
with white it's a pretty big tournament
shake oh let's look at our favorite
favorite one of our favorites this
liliane game I wasn't we were I was
unhappy last time with the way things
had gone with white and now I'm not sure
at all what's going on
after the time scramble it is blacks
move and so like I like whitey
the king is in the play and blacks king
is not well at the very least we've got
rook g1 and that we can bounce back and
forth okay
rip g1 but let's say that this is an
achievement for Lily and of God this I
thought because let's just see how this
happens so yeah he was I thought he was
doing it's a whole mess of course
happened here oh man this is we left
this we left this ages ago and where
were we we were like here Bishop f4 was
played and this was kind of a funny
moment cuz I thought 94 was at least
instant equality and maybe I'm missing
something there but that's what I
thought
Queenie 7 does look strange to me f6
makes a lot of sense what do you do
where do you do it buddy what happens
this doesn't make sense at all to me
I don't know how this this is at least
how we got what we got
so rookie one was played and as I
expected that we're getting this kind of
thing oh and it looks like we actually
have a result here in the HOH Cobian
game it looks like you know that's funny
I was predicting that game was gonna be
a draw ages ago
and those guys really played it out so
you know for those of for those in the
chest community that want to oh no I'm
sorry I was talking I was think about a
different game
yes so in this one it looks like white
is actually resigning or he's checkmated
or what happens well this was our
business where we talked about before
where he was just down the extreme right
yeah so this so that one actually
progressed pretty quickly
yeah I guess they didn't quite make time
pressure I need the time control rather
all right so that's in Group C the count
continues to be looking lost and L Shawn
is considering how to recapture the pawn
on d6 this is a very technical endgame I
think for both players this looks like a
tough one but luckily if if a takes b6
the bishop controls the queening square
I've been led to believe that this is a
good thing let's let's try a b6 and let
me just do the move that scares me
and then on b7 I'm not G for this is a
problem so that's why the basic mate is
not gonna work hold on is it a problem
you checked me i play king g6 good move
so we're gonna have to say check to the
miserable King King age six now maybe
you can the King age six will let me
draw maybe you can do this and try to
win my goodness rook F or okay four but
I take it and it's still a mate threat
pawn takes that for anyway that's
interesting yeah my nonsense no actually
we have Gordievsky here ready to join
you
so I'm gonna go ahead and
excused myself from the communicators
chair and let him come in to talk to you
it's sure so while we're waiting for him
to come in let's just get a quick update
as to what's going on and we haven't
talked about Gawain's game in a while
and I was predicting that this was kind
of a comfortable or at least semi
governor bull fortress things have
progressed and the obvious question is
can Geoffrey enter with the king in some
way Gawain's clearly set himself up for
fortress style stuff he's just going to
hang out and say that there's yeah it's
very difficult you can't win this pawn
you can't win this pawn and the King
will tend to this form so unless waking
the chief King f5 in some meaningful way
you know that's not going to be
available all right so we have Dimitri
in this yeah we have Igor in the studio
with us and we're gonna take a look at
Oh
Dimitri's in the studio sorry guys I got
it all wrong this was a crazy game yeah
and yeah I mean I did find Ross and I
thought that even if I drove to there
anyway come here because it's like I
mean I think I played well but and then
in the end of the game I wasn't able to
convert my advantage again and again
because I had chances in all my games
but today it seems like we're a sport
yeah yeah yeah I mean I didn't expect
him for because he usually before 93c
for player uh-huh and I think that he
prepared something for sebacean eco
which I play usually last time right or
me should be five this stuff which
happened in second round against
Jacobson here
yeah this line I played quite a lot I
play tonight have Sikhs Bishop c5 97 all
lines but I assume that general speaking
kids this line is just bad for black
right yeah yeah but I'm quite tired of
making draw Santa okay let's try to
forget to get play I thought the guy
should have just taken on c6 and play
that four or something like that you
know no I mean the strongest move of
course is Bishop III I'm not seeing what
she like I've played this and it's
according to computer it's not like like
plus one because there's line 90 for
Bishop before knight c6 Bishop c3 be 5p3
I should play e5 to avoid pressure on g7
phone yes yeah he five and here Marcus
team played before if I'm not mistaken
and then just 92 and for some reason it
was just bad for black f4 it's mf4 at
some point yeah Oh a four if my before
black plays d6 right yeah a full black
plays d6 to defend pawn on e5 and then
white plays it sounds like a 14-4 in a
correct moment okay okay but what he
played I already had one game 93 so hear
it right it felt like the knight is
misplaced don't be here right yeah so
but anyway I don't believe that it's a
good full black well yeah you get you've
got this other guy hanging out back here
you got it in stuff that way right yeah
but if I play the six ninety seventy in
some positions even don't lose the tempo
because for example 96 96 97 and for 97
96 night
yeah so here he had a variety of moves
like I don't know c4 and everything he
goes this way 93 looks logical looks
like yeah for b5 and here's the question
is how to put pieces in the best way I
think that place for queen is on h5
uh-huh to provoke g6 at some moment so
maybe right now maybe right now Queen
age - because I played a game against a
virgin in Russian championship he played
a sneak in which one and something like
that but also he did two videos for
YouTube uh-huh and he commented this
game and said that after queen h5 was
just clearly better for why it is so
easy to play and like is just a terrible
position but I decided okay even if it's
bad but let's I mean when you play the
return you kind of expect some weird
thing like this day of course yeah yeah
I mean even if it's static like +1 or
white still have to prove something
right because a lot of things to
calculate at 35 sure yeah because I
think that Queen III was logical anyways
it cannot be a bad move its normal place
for Queen but the problem right for
white is he has to do something he has
to hurt you yes that's what I mean I
think that something like Queen h3 might
be possible uh-huh because now I have to
think can i castle or not but a costly v
g6 it should be better for white but if
you don't cancel what you can play g6
what do you want to do I don't know it
seems like castle is the only move yeah
I mean like win ce7 - or oopsie aged
over there
f5 could be dangerous Mako's pawn on e6
is not defended even here even here
maybe f5 yeah there are five I've been
forced to play he take a five
yeah well yeah maybe you have other
moves here because queening Street I
don't want the night before is the
possibility night before you know I
didn't mean to do that sorry
uh-huh maybe this looks wrong but maybe
night c-5 it doesn't look right to me
but yeah I almost wasn't sure what is
that yeah because I don't remember this
position after 95/65 and didn't see any
game right I mean it is in this
structure I mean right right but here
maybe it's good because we should on G 2
is not defined with mr. Pond III I think
it would be just bad but but here here
maybe this is this is good move and the
question is after night C which night I
want to change 95 93 or 94 93 right okay
and so the problem let's see so what
actually maybe we could ask what do you
think whites so he's just saying I could
take it slow I'm gonna like he played
this so quickly no I mean he couldn't I
don't believe that he ever seen this
position before right so I was really
surprised that a for because already I
felt here you were looking like he's
putting some difficult questions yes yes
because generally speaking I didn't see
that after okay
he won when I played Bishop f6 right we
should be to this line I mean we will be
back at some moment and I didn't see it
first point after 94 Bishop e3 take take
96 and firstly I thought that I can play
night before and then I I mean I went to
waiting room and sitting in there a
logitech I can just play Knight e5
instead of night before and I'm winning
immediately
oh nice no yeah yeah 95 and 93 check I
think that it is what he missed
however even after night before I think
that time if not better I am
definitely okay take on beasts and Queen
b6 Queen III Queen b7 e 593 Queen 33 I
thought that I can even play Rudy 8
sacrificing safely upon and right and
it's again because this night isn't
working
yes that's why this whole thing is no
good huh okay
however it doesn't make sense because I
have 95 right but I mean even even this
attack like there's I don't I couldn't
understand how he could ever get things
moving because yes because I also I
think that Rukia one was a big mistake
because in this position I think that
I'm already much greater because I
there is no something forced a while
what do you think he should do
that's the question nice if or maybe Oh
Group B one there's two ways to defend
pawn this would be a sad thing but yeah
median is 94 one I was trying to
understand what is dead after Queen c7
you know one amazing thing is you still
have your 95 trick so he's not actually
threatening it right yeah what I just
play something say g6 to develop pieces
yeah g6 cent
oh wait that's good because then 95 he
could take and then f6 yeah okay but you
have a lot of different moves you could
play I thought that I can play a quince
yourselves sure yeah and it looks kind
of logic over Queen h3 I think that it
was critical on Queen you could also
play 96 right 96
I'm sure I didn't like something but I
don't remember maybe you were worried
about some kind of weird ePHI some kind
of ability for I would yeah I mean it's
always difficult to copulate a lot of
lines right you it looks like though I
can take it with the night because this
guy sang yeah still okay yes 996 I know
96 I didn't like night Knight a5 I mean
oh here 95 I thought that it's really
unpleasant and I didn't see Sun star
something good yeah okay yeah because
they take in severe tour so I want to
play Queen c7 yeah
Queen h3 g6 everything first and here
why should push but how I don't know
well right it's very eco life maybe if I
face a possibility but you never know
after we take a 5p take a five mmm-hmm
it's not on see boys a little bit
misplaced here I mean it's weird like
what what he got from doing this a
fourth thing right it's almost like if
you're gonna do this then I don't know
yeah I don't know a five is your idea I
don't know what what it is you know so
yeah okay well let's look at the game so
Rick 81 yes because this looks very
pleasant yeah already a third it's it's
a big advantage for me it should be
right but maybe you you since nothing no
it looked at I I don't know it looks
like you have the more the safer King
now - yeah right
also I could time advantage and I think
it's very difficult to play for white
and all my moves are quite easy this is
this was the critical moment after
Bishop c4 it was a good move definitely
but but here I started to
didn't like for some reason my position
say I couldn't find a good move
why is that looked like a good move yeah
that but firstly I want to quit
something like rook c8 uh-huh
and then my night after night d4 it was
night c2 is it right here
94 you can sacrifice somehow only six in
some moment and yeah 93 95 so I wasn't
sure not afraid no night if you just
take however here not so easy for black
holes to find because f5 is kind of
scary here huh because you can't
sacrifice night not rook it could easily
become unpleasant public but to Queen b6
I'm sure is the best one and I guess you
were all your Knight b6 you had some
worry to right like you were worried
about I just didn't want to move my
pieces too far from my okay yeah this
may be 96 is a good move but I mean as
long as he doesn't have any tricks right
then the knight on p3 is out and your
king is safer your bishop is beautiful
yeah I just super fine I just should
carefully calculate all lines yeah it's
really nice yes of course
after 94 so I couldn't play Bishop d5
instead of Queen d7 you can't just take
with Bishop we take D 594 I was thinking
even if I if that game I will be not
able to convert my advantage would be
just ridiculous
so here yes it was the critical move or
otherwise I'm just very comfortable
because I cannot defend my night with
Queen g7 there is just through d7
resign right
so very pleasant all of us yeah I just
Oh ma'am so I guess I'm hearing from the
tone of your voice that you were
traumatized by your earlier rounds and
you convert this visit yes okay no I
mean I don't remember when I did
something like that like here five
dollars hi France five boroughs and
always I had the possibility to get big
advantage on the only game against
modern body mm-hmm there was some crazy
stuff for Ruby Dee - I think you saw
that right yeah and he also didn't see
that he went for this line which is just
losing if not Rosie - right and I was I
mean so super surprised that you could
find it and again again I had chances
and I mean I converted very poorly well
here you are in this looks yeah here
here five yeah nice just to avoid
negative six and I'm sure Kim is just
you just blundered at room be one but
otherwise it I don't know how to play
for for white I just want to play evil
not Ruby one I just want to engage a
troop Jade in g5y a very simple playing
yeah yeah and then I wish we just
decided this was lost
no I could I could to to make two moves
right i if I'm not mistaken a 38 move
and I am sure that it would be will be
very difficult to blunder something into
moves here public and if I'm not blonder
I'm just meaning because I get that
means more so yeah I feel like you're
you're a plus-one right yeah and
everything to play for here and who you
know who knows what's gonna what do you
get your take on this position over here
with the tournament leaders okay okay
oh it's it's been a wild game yes yes I
thought that this it had to be big
advantage for Hawaii it's a moment where
it isn't be Farfan it looked now however
there is a mate right here know what I
mean
how to avoid it I don't see it seems
like Ruby Jade isn't only move otherwise
we're just as I know okay thirty-eight
yes and here we have five
and it doesn't look good I mean I don't
understand
maybe I don't see something maybe you
could go this probably isn't gonna work
but I'm gonna try really the only move
by Franco yes and then what rook yet you
got to go rook F - this isn't gonna work
no this isn't gonna work
yeah I mean I just think they can ID one
chick Kinsey seeks and I'm sure yeah
it's gotta be one yeah so let's this
yeah let's look at cuz it was really fun
oh he played OG v look there's okay
let's go to the video g5 yeah but what
is what is his idea
well if King g5 he wants Bishop f4 I
guess right he haven't and that's what
happened yeah but after after Queen age
five it seems like it's still the main
thread he still cannot play the same
well he's gonna take on e3 all I mean is
just and then it just no kicking h5
because after Queen f5
I think v7 is the idea when it's gonna
fire and with missile but here it still
is still made yeah oh that's why you
didn't want to go King f5 yes give it
Oh else Shawn what a bummer so this some
really changes I mean this is just five
more moves before this this even they
came out of time pressure when they got
this business yes and the dynamic is
already set black has to make made
threats or else he's gonna lose right of
course
so black did play King f5 but I still
know it's there is even no times which
move is that it's 41 moves so what
definitely had time here no that's what
I mean they came out it's time scramble
here yes it just kind of started and
here was where we cut it looks like
Blake is trying to survive here
well maybe let's ask this question why
because g4 is already feels a little bit
like yes it's very very so what's wrong
with B cell b7 but I mean it's made into
a 444 92 right so that's already can't
do so that's why you got to do it yeah
the only move is Ruby Jade seems like
King f5 yes and here it's still made
threat G for 992 rook h7 at the end yeah
but can i play some something like Luke
which is heaven
but
it looks like black and white g4 and
Luigi - yeah or or yes something or even
Ruby a but g4 would be too short and
this guy sang yes
no I wanted to play g5 check can be four
and seven and it looks like I just we
need it's clearly shocked
oh we're four times you know yesterday L
Shana I thought was totally lost against
bread and then Brandon walked this Queen
to the king side here's King to the
Queen side I don't know if you saw that
they get added up winning the game
he's you can see the look all right well
thanks for coming in what's your best of
luck think your hand will be falling
down here for your games
thank you very much good to see and so
we'll wrap it up here and maybe go
through some of the final games the
count last time we left was in
difficulty down several pawns we're
gonna say still in difficulty but he's
gonna fight on and yegor yegor Kovalenko
one against Ganguly that's gonna really
shake things up in the beat the B group
Friedman when we last left was losing to
Samuel and I guess that's still the case
after this right still looks rough white
is gonna try to hold on count create
some kind of play with the past seep on
and maybe he even has something going on
I'm actually let's let's update that
white just played Bishop h3 and it's
dreaming of a Merry Christmas with c7
shouldn't work but at least these cuts
up they go I got the least black I
assume can play takes on f6 and then
bish
v6 Wow yeah what what a game and what an
what a finish to else Sean's try against
the group si leader archers Mike Suns so
that game a little bit further ahead
yeah that was a brutal loss promotion
and you know he beat Brandon and a
brutal loss the last round and then this
time he suffers the same fate right
sometimes when you're pressing you have
the nice position it's kind of a it's a
burden it's a burden because you want to
prove your position then you end up
taking unnecessary risks I think what
happened difficult stuff so why don't we
wrap it up here we can take maybe one
last look at what's going on in the
place look at that let's look at the
fortress game which might go on forever
all right and so we have got Geoffrey
against going Jones here right and
Gawain's gonna say that once I clear the
h-bond that I've got no grief at all so
here he goes and he says I'm clearing
the h-bond and I have no problems so
white house if that's true why believes
that he's gonna try to do something
fancy maybe like g4 however g4 carries
its own risks because of you know then
you're giving my mean Knight f4 right so
expecting a draw from this game then
like managing to simplify I put his
pieces on solid squares and so I don't
think there's there's too much here
anymore I guess you win this this round
of guess the result a lot of faith in
the Queen I like you know I think black
had a number of ways to achieve the
fortress but this one it's very solid
and actually you know I think one of the
difficulties of learning chess is
learning how to identify the fortress
both as the attacker and the defender
and I've been the victim several times
as the attacker with some genius I'm
playing creates a fortress and what
we're looking at here anyways what I
meant to say though is when you get a
position like wing got way back when
let's say here mm-hmm
you have to be able to visualize or try
to visualize what the final
situation is that you're looking for and
really I moved 28 he gets it really on
let's say move 45 over here something
like this in the game the white played
King f3 here so we're assuming something
like hg king g3 anyways and and we're
gonna say that it's you know it's still
actually something white compressed as
long as he it can somehow get the King
into f5 he can claim that he's got at
least practical chances and maybe that's
true so a lot still going on here then
Caleb could still be proven right - they
may be we'll see what it was I think you
know Jeffery is the kind of guy this is
where I move 44 I'm gonna predict move a
hundred move a hundred alright hundred
that was what that was the amount of
loose that Sam won in his last round
seven Shanklin when a very nice game
against daro and we didn't get to cover
that game we might come back to that
game at some point cuz that was a real
technical masterpiece which allowed Sam
to come back into potential contention
well let's see where we actually stand
after this round looking at the
standings David Howell one of the
tournament co-leaders drew his game
putting him at three and a half
Jeffery of course is trying to press
trying to squeeze something in his game
if he were to win that game he would
jump to Seoul first if he were to draw
of course he's still tied for the lead
with David Howe going Jones is of course
Jeffrey's victim for the day maybe maybe
he'll hold on with with no issues though
Liam Lee is playing as Darius weirds and
it looks like actually has quite a few
chances in his game so we'll keep an eye
on that you are welcome to follow all
these games to their conclusion at us
chess champs calm but let's just finish
up here and look at the B group Gregorio
/ Andrew his game bring him to four
points three ganguly this is big news
lost his game so he's no longer its hide
for the top spot with Grigory boozy
Andrew against Grigory Oberon Igor
Kovalenko was the man to take down
today bringing him up to two points of
course Sam is pressing against Daniel
Friedman and we still wait to see that
the result of that game and lastly over
in Group C archers Naik sons extends his
lead with a victory over L Shawn Murad
II Abadi after quite a lot of turbulence
quite a lot of uncertainty in that game
Dmitry Gordievsky of course was gracious
enough to come down here for an
interview after his big win I guess
around poco bian and we wait to see
Brandon Jacobsen we think he's going to
pull out his game against the count
Christian sure Allah bring him up to
three points as well right so thank you
so much for joining us here on the
summer chess classic of course in just
two days time the grand chest tour is
starting up once again in Croatia
so June 26 so in two days you'll be able
to watch our broadcast of that
tournament and then once that broadcast
finishes up or at 3:30 p.m. whichever
comes first
watch whichever comes second rather we
will be back here with more coverage of
the summer chess classic but so as to
get two for the price of one that day
two different coverages so that should
be very exciting of course after Croatia
we actually have the US Junior
Championship the US girls junior
championship and for the first time ever
the u.s. Senior Championship with
players over 50 getting a chance to
shine once again actually I think that's
going to be just about it for us today
Jesse thank you so much for joining us
here of course my name is Caleb Ben be
joined by G I'm Jesse cry and be sure to
join us tomorrow for round seven of the
summer chess classic
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
[Music]
you